on a d'autres qui ont porté plainte
auprès de moi auprès du conseil de
l'ordre et vous comprendrez bien que
même limite c'est une des limites à la
convivialité
je n'aime pas qu'on insulte je n'aime
pas qu'on porte plainte contre moi a
qu'à prendre demande de débattre en
toute sérénité
je le fais pas et donc je vous le dis
très solennellement et après avoir juré
de dire la vérité je n'ai jamais fraudé
de ma vie j'ai écrit 3500 publications
internationales
je n'en ai jamais rétracté aucune alors
bien entendu sur 3500 il y a eu des
erreurs qui sont passés pour l'instant
il ya une fille qui me traquent la une
chasseuse de têtes depuis que je suis
célèbre qui a réussi à trouver cinq
erreurs sur 3500 il y en a probablement
beaucoup plus que ça j'estime qu'il ya
entre 2 et 4 % d'erreurs dans les
papiers que j'ai fait et donc je ne
serais pas étonné qu'on trouve d'autres
erreurs mais je dois vous dire que je ne
suis qu'un pauvre humain que je fais des
erreurs comme tout le monde mais de
m'accuser sur une tribune officiellement
de fraude de mettre son nom là dessus et
et de penser que je vais débattre avec
c'est au dessus de mes forces et je vous
demande de me pardonner de ne pas avoir
la force de discuter sereinement avec
des gens qui m'insultent je le ferai pas
je ferai jamais